good morning believe nation today's
messages don't let the haters pull you
down over to you drink no I think every
time I say I'm about to do something
people are waiting for me to fumbled
that's probably one of the biggest
motivations behind a lot of my raps is
the amount of people that want me to
fall or whatever I think that that
should be the motivation for most
rappers you know the further you climb
towards the top the more the more hands
you have on your pant leg dragging you
to the bottom they just start tugging at
you but you know I wear really strong
pants whenever you try doing something
big in your life you're gonna get the
haters you're gonna get the people who
just hate on what you're doing who point
out all the reasons why it's not gonna
work and if you listen to them then
you're never going to go out and
accomplish your big goal I haven't told
this story in a while so I think is
worth revisiting
I see entrepreneurs as gladiators you
wake up every day and you fight for your
dream right you train you work hard you
go into the arena you fight you fight
for your dream you fight for your family
you fight for your community you fight
for yourself right you're up every day
working on your business fighting and
you do it in a very public way because
you have people who are watching right
your friends your family the community
they're watching you as you do this and
they're watching you make mistakes
because at the beginning you're gonna
suck you're gonna make mistakes you're
gonna fail and they're watching you fall
down they're watching you make mistake
over mistake over mistake and it can be
embarrassing it can be hard to fail with
people around you but that's what the
gladiator entrepreneur does every single
day you get back up and you go fight
again the haters are the little man as I
like to call it they're the people who
are too afraid to be the gladiator he's
the guy who's too afraid to step into
the ring he's the guy who's just
standing up in his seats with his
comfortable seats laughing at you joking
at you throwing popcorn at you hurling
insults at you because he's too afraid
to be an entrepreneur himself he's too
afraid to step into the ring himself and
maybe he tried once right maybe he
wasn't always a little man
maybe he tried once and it didn't work
out and now he's convinced that it's
never gonna work out for him and that
life sucks and that every but everything
should suck and he's just gonna be a
negative person and it's not enough to
live a mediocre life for him he needs to
pull everybody down with him - right
he's got to bring you into his black
black hole of mediocrity because he
wasn't able to be successful therefore
nobody else around him can be successful
either the other thing about the little
man is that you're gonna have holes in
your plan right you have a big dream you
have a big plan you want to accomplish
something massive you haven't figured it
all out yet right maybe you just came up
with the idea last night and you go and
tell somebody about it and they're gonna
say oh that's not gonna work because of
X Y Z right anybody who starts off as a
sentence with oh that's not gonna work
because right you need to eliminate from
your life that's the little man in
action because of course there are holes
in your plan you don't have all the
answers
you know where you want to go but you
don't quite know how you're gonna get
there where your real friends are going
with people who understand those
problems see the holes and try to help
you solve them whether it's just through
emotional guidance and support or where
there's actually giving you practical
hands-on strategies and suggestions on
how to accomplish your dream so stop
listening to the little man stop paying
attention to the haters because the
bigger your project is the more haters
you're gonna get stay on your course
notice coming from a good place
and if you want to have a massive impact
on the world that's just part of the
process is dealing with and eliminating
the little man haters from your life
believe so the question of the day today
is who was the biggest hater or little
man in your life leave it in the
comments below and I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press
this recipe Viggo